the question on everyone's mind is tell
us how you are I am you know I'm okay
I'm keep going one foot in front of the
others I mean obviously you know this is
a difficult time I'm heartbroken but I'm
grateful to have my job and be dressed
and up out of the bed yes that on
Twitter that you two had grown apart how
did that happen
it's life work my held his job the
children life is overwhelming for
everybody and it's a lot of work to keep
it all together Yolanda is still
battling Lyme disease which makes her
split with David such a shocking story
in the new season of The Real Housewives
of Beverly Hills what signs did you see
that this was coming
none it's a sad sad sad thing divorce at
last night's premiere all seven ladies
were there even former series regular
Brandi Glanville drops by and Camille
Rivers what about you you're looking
great tonight are you dating anyone
master what's happening you have a
friend a special friend did you meet
this special friend I've known him for a
while he's our friend we're working on a
house together where I bought a house
and renovating and he's a real estate
agent so we're working on the house
house to move into together yes not in
two together no no I'm moving in with my
children no I'm not ready for that but
since you're happy I'm very happy yes
you